pub life is back but different the old
familiar is unfamiliar stickers leading
to the bar
hand sanitizer on the wall and you need
to give your details for track and trace
on entry I'm just glad to get bite
another few frames at the same time it's
a risk opening the pub's but we got a
finger peep people's mental health as
well I thought it'd be a lot busier than
it is but it's nice to kind of get back
to normal there is a threat to the near
normality theme parks are open if you've
booked in advance Thorpe Park in Surrey
took 2,000 visitors today a fifth of its
capacity the swarm
roller coaster soars through a
post-apocalyptic world and post lockdown
adds to the strangeness seats are
sanitized between the rides of masked
different it's not as quite a good buzz
is not as good there's not many people
here but that's nice because the queues
the lower I literally just went on
bumper cars loads all you need to do is
have a mass to go on a ride now it just
feels normal again it's nice for that
normalization just it feels good bit
disappointing they're not all open but
obviously government guidelines it has
to be a certain degree of safety
ultimately this is an experiment nobody
knows what this easing back to normality
will bring and a lot will depend on how
we behave and whilst it is essential for
the economy it is also a potential
opportunity for the virus
now the government that tells us that
the our factory is between point seven
point nine still that our factor is
already too high if we're trying to get
rid of the virus in Britain as quickly
as possible with pubs bars restaurants
hairdressers and cinemas opening today I
can only advise people be utterly
cautious for many the real excitement
worth queuing for today was a simple
haircut it's my first time back in the
salon since before lockdown and I'm
finally being pampered and it feels
great I hopefully get my color sorted
what makes this Saturday super depends
on what you've been missing for some
it's bingo others might have to wait
till Wednesday when the National Gallery
becomes the first major art museum to
reopen the message is be careful having
climbed out of lockdown we are dipping
into the unknown
Jason Farrell Sky News